Donald Trump did a couple of whacked out
interviews the first of which is on a
platform called Americano Media or
Americano in other words it's a right
wing it it's new they get like 2 000
views of video it's quite wild it's a
right wing
American Spanish language Outlet or
Channel I don't even really know what to
call it and this is I guess where Donald
Trump is now being interviewed these
clips are sometimes only getting a
couple thousand views this particular
one has seven thousand views and this is
where Trump's now being interviewed the
topic of Elon musk's takeover of Twitter
came up this has been a big point of
contention is Trump going back to
Twitter if he is unbanned which would of
course completely torpedo truth social
Trump says he's not with truth social
yeah and the opportunity to have freedom
of speech which is very important for
democracy right and now knowing that
Elon Musk has take control of Twitter do
you see that there is an opportunity for
a broader freedom of speech in this
country that can help you know ease up
all these ideas and all this censorship
that the you know many people have been
submitted to in the past few years it's
very good that Elon took over Twitter it
was run by Maniacs radical left lunatics
and they were
I mean it was all Bots and fake accounts
a lot of it and it was a disaster okay
and I had hundreds of millions of people
between Facebook and Twitter more than
just about anybody else
and all of a sudden one day you don't
have your voice anymore and I created
after telling all sorts of corrosive
lies and inciting violence right that's
the little detail he lives suddenly my
voice was gone after I did a b c d e all
in violation of Twitter's terms of
service truth social and it's been
amazingly successful it's almost
bankrupt last week as you saw it was
above Tic Tac it was above Twitter it
was about it it's been an amazing
success so you know I like it I'm saying
on Truth social I like it better yep so
Trump is staying on truth truth Central
is where he will be staying Donald Trump
in a moment that makes no sense
whatsoever says he thinks the search
warrant at Mar-A-Lago will make Hispanic
people vote for him but Trump thinks
everything will make Hispanic people
vote for him we don't straighten this
country out you're going to end up you
are literally going to end up with a
Venezuela on steroids meaning a bigger
version of Venezuela and that's where
our country is going if you look at
what's happening yeah the raid on
Mar-A-Lago
people were disgusted by it
but
Hispanics saw that as what happened and
many of them come from countries that we
know very well oh God is he saying that
when a search warrant was served at
Mar-A-Lago it was like the abuses of
power corruption and dictatorial
Insanity in Venezuela is that is that
the argument he's making
they said that's what happened
from where they came
oh God that is just Rich a completely
legal uh eyes dotted and T's crossed uh
search warrant being executed when there
is so much probable cause that's like
that's like what Chavez did that is just
wild
um and Trump actually talks more about
Venezuela you take a look at Venezuela
go back 20 years Venezuela very
prosperous rich country it was the
richest country in Latin America it was
you know everything was pretty good
and now you look they don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
anything they have a dictatorship
and on the campaign I was saying that if
we don't straighten this country out
you're going to end up you are literally
going to end up with a Venezuela on
steroids there you go and I have to tell
you Trump finally getting something
right it is true I believe in the year
2001 or 2000 Venezuela was
um the most prosperous country in South
America that he he finally stumbled
across a historical fact that is true
Trump is now also doing the communism
stuff without understanding a word of it
well the American dream will be gone the
American dream with Communism is never
going to be here
and you know once it goes there it's
very hard to bring it back yes well of
course there are no Communists in
positions of power in the United States
there just aren't any and then Trump
confirming he doesn't even know what
these terms even mean I think that the
election coming up on the eighth and the
following election very importantly
which is now think of it it's two years
away it's very quick quick how it
happens time flies
uh I think if we don't do well in those
two elections our country is gone
and I really believe we pass socialism
you know we've just stepped over
socialism we're into communism that's
what's happening if you look at the
justice department the FBI you look at
the kind of things that are going on
with
law enforcement and what they're doing
we have forgotten them so he's gone from
supporting law enforcement to now that
the FBI served a search warrant at
Mar-A-Lago
law enforcement is evidence of Communism
about socialism we're into communism
we're into Soviet Union stuff
it's very bad and it's very dangerous
for this country and people are angry
about it yeah Trump continuing to have
no idea what socialism is what communism
is the difference between the two or
whether there's any of it here in the
United States as orange and sweaty as
ever and even the friendliest interviews
he just cannot make any sense before you
go if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description